I'm not bald I'm not bald I'm not bald I
am not bald I am not bald I'm not bald
I'm not bought
clears your guys's hair mine's brown
brown mine's like an Auburn type of
color Okay mine's brown as well yeah
that's like brown mine's just like
naturally black but I dyed my hair so
yeah me too
mine's red
how long is everyone's hair mine's
pretty long I cut my hair recently so
it's like up to my collarbones now my
hair is pretty long like past my
shoulders it's impressive every single
day a customer at my work asks me if I'm
wearing a wig do you wear wigs I feel
like if I thought someone was wearing a
wig I would not ask them if they were
wearing a wig have you worn wigs because
that's kind of rude when will you wear
wigs
oh
mine does not even past my ears mine's
like Jaw blinks yeah mine's like down in
my butt what is your guys's like um like
do you guys because I only shampoo my
hair like once a week and like okay okay
good because people tell me like you
gotta do it every other day or something
yeah yeah well I used to like shampoo my
hair every single day and then like I
heard it was really bad yeah yeah I'm
trying to like lessen it out but like it
gets so oily and like I just don't want
to look back but you want the natural
oils to do their thing it'll be like a
week or two and then the oil will go
away and then you can like build up to
washing it like two times a week to even
one I only wash my hair like once a
month maybe oh wow
wow
I just I don't know actually yeah
actually maybe like every two to three
weeks I just like I don't know I don't
really wash my hair that often a lot of
dry shampoo yeah
not really honestly how does your hair
not get oily usually if you have long
hair you have to like wash your hair
pretty often or else it will build up
and will get really nasty yeah when I
was in high school this guy that I
thought was really cool was like I'm
doing this thing called No poo where I
don't wash my hair and I was like I want
to be you so I just kind of stopped
washing my hair and I just do it every
time you know it gets a little I don't
know my hair doesn't really get oily but
I do have like dandruff problems
sometimes so once I get start seeing
some dandruff then I'll wash it do you
have like a specific shampoo you use for
like for your dandruff I used to use
Head and Shoulders but now I'm just
using the Trader Joe's tea tree tingle
who teaches
so it was kind of crazy when Sean said
that he only washed his hair once a
month I never heard anyone say that
before does anyone mind if we touch each
other's hair you can touch my hair yeah
it's going to be hard
[Music]
it's so hard
I'm a hair stylist so I felt like me
feeling the hair was kind of gonna give
it away a little bit Oscar's hair kind
of felt like he had a toupee on yeah
it's like a collab
so soft
did you say that you had a firm yeah I
had a Perma a year ago and dude it's
still very much I know because I don't
wash my hair did you put like some
product in your hair like Hairspray
maybe today yeah no it felt fake and
synthetic but maybe he just needs to
wash it more
[Music]
super healthy
guys I knew this was gonna happen
my hair just has a unique texture it's
kind of weird because I got a perm a
year ago it's like got these unnatural
curls I mean they are like chemically
made
oh it's so bright no one really seems
like they're bald here at all
everyone has insecurities like what's an
insecurity that you guys have had about
your hair before
um the side is thicker than the other
really yeah I can't really tell when I
was in Middle School I had my hair like
down to here and it was constantly
bullied for it for like a year and then
it was just like cut it off and
everyone's completely changed what's
everybody's go-to style I just pull mine
down so you don't see my big forehead
because farther down the hair goes
that's why I have bangs as well because
my forehead's like up down here so like
after I got like my bangs I just like
felt so much more really confident in
myself if a wig is fake you can tell it
doesn't match their coloring so like
pink hair it's like maybe it's a wig can
somebody do like can somebody like show
us like your go-to like hair like show
off your hair yeah
yeah
just a little flip Claire was a bit
suspicious because she was very careful
with how she moved her hair and how she
touched it was very delicate how about
you or just just that there you go
whatever it works but it's not going to
be long for too much longer you're gonna
cut it I actually had an appointment but
uh my barber's kind of sick you don't
cheat on your Barber don't do that
because I'm a hair stylist
oh wow that's cool I won't I promise
thank you
good luck you guys thank you maybe I
should have parted my hair differently
maybe I shouldn't have hair put
hairspray in my hair because I was
thinking oh my gosh they're gonna think
this is fake because of the way it feels
if you think the mall still in the box
and you'd like to continue playing the
game please raise your hand
we're going to start off this round with
bald filter selfies
[Music]
okay okay nice nice
you can pull it off my dad's bald so it
might happen so oh
[Music]
okay okay that works
wait wait no yeah that looks really good
that looks really good for sure have you
guys seen Spy Kids those little fingers
that's what that looks like that's what
that looks like right here
oh
[Laughter]
so bad
but it's just so bad I I couldn't I
couldn't pull this off no way not at all
so have any of you guys like because
I've experienced like balding because my
dad's bald so I've been taking medicine
for it have any guys like experienced
hair loss or anything like that
um yeah no not really because I'm I'm
like pretty young I haven't like
experienced any of that yet I have like
a cowlick like where like I don't really
have a lot of hair so I have to cover it
like this but well it works if you do
yeah who did you use to grow your hair
back I used this man I went to the
dermatologist and they prescribed it's
called like finasteride yeah because I
was asking about like the hems treatment
and they said it only is like one in
seven chance of it working so they
prescribed it and I started taking it
about like six months ago but I've
already noticed like a massive
difference on top of my head so I'm glad
that's working yeah thank you yeah
my hair used to be like really long it
used to come down to like past my ears
and I shaved it all off so like to redo
the medicine and see how it would grow
in so I've just been wearing hats
recently to try and get it to at least
come back past my you said what I would
recommend would be nioxin then
keep your hair growing oh really okay
but once you start using it you have to
use it yeah or else your hair will fall
out so I'll look that up I'll definitely
so what are you guys this relationship
with your hair how do you feel torture
her is it your personality when I was
younger I didn't like it a lot because I
got made fun of obviously because red
hair but yeah I didn't really care back
then I still don't care but like ginger
yeah Carrot Tops oh yeah but then I grew
up to love it because I'm like not a lot
of people have this hair color like it's
pretty cool to have I know a lot of
black women who always have a negative
um connotation with their hair when it
comes to
outwardly presenting it but I've always
just loved my hair like my hair it's
shorter right now but my hair used to be
like down my back too so I've just never
really had that towards my hair like
most like women do and that's actually
I'm grateful for that yeah
[Music]
oh my God
because I've bleached it so much I I
know that it felt like a bit more dry
compared to like normal hair if you
think the mole is still in the box and
you'd like to continue playing the game
please raise your hand
the lights turn green that means you
have voted the mole out and you all win
the lights turn red that means the mole
is still in the box and you lose
and three
two
[Music]
one
area good job guys if you like this
episode and you want to see more make
sure to like this video And subscribe to
our Channel now let's figure out who the
mole is the count of three the more will
reveal themselves and
three
two one
yeah
okay oh
yes girls yeah you look very good oh wow
I touch it yeah you guys but the part
looks so natural I know I think oh yeah
I actually have alopecia I have
absolutely no hair no eyebrows yeah no
eyelashes
immediately you get your eyebrows like
that and they're like tattoos for people
with hair loss wow wow yeah that's
awesome
see the eyebrows like coming off
yeah so did you start with like traction
alopecia or was it just um I had
alopecia areata oh okay like bald spots
around the scalp and then it wasn't
until College when I got like
universalis so like I used to have
eyelashes eyebrows I've never had armor
leg hair so now I'm just completely
hairless you are not your hair hair does
not define you it doesn't make you any
less feminine it's badass being bald
like it's almost a trend these days bye
you feel bad